that's right one of the
core historical insights is people
should move jobs
and this applies for ceos probably
absolutely apps they can go
become ceo somewhere else but don't stay
ceo one place too long
it's a problem with startups right the
founder you can have a brilliant founder
and that founder doesn't want to let go
yeah right it's the same issue
at the same time i mean this is where
elon musk and
a few others like uh larry page and
sergey brin
that stayed for quite a long time and
they actually were the beacon
they on their shoulders carried the
dream the company
yeah where everybody else doubted so but
that seems to be the exception
right versus the rule well and even
sergey for example right
has stepped back right he plays less of
a day-to-day role and
is not running google in the way he did
the interesting thing is he stepped back
in a quite tragic way from what i've
seen which is
i i think google's mission an initial
mission
of making the world's information
accessible to everybody
is one of the most beautiful missions of
any company in the history of the world
i think it's
what google has done with a search
engine and
um and other efforts that are similar
like scanning
a lot of books it's just incredible it's
similar to
wikipedia but
what he said was that it's not the same
company
anymore and i i know maybe i'm reading
too much into it
because it's more maybe practically
saying just the size of the company's
much larger the kind of leadership
that's required
but at the same time sure they changed
the model from you know
don't be evil to it's becoming
corporatized and all those kinds of
things and
it's sad it um there also are cycles
right history is about cycles right
there there are cycles to life
there's cycles to organizations it's sad
i mean it said steve jobs leaving apple
by
passing away said you know what the
future of spacex
and tesla looks like without elon musk
is quite sad
it's very possible that those companies
become something very different
they become something much more you know
like corporate and
uh stale
yeah so maybe maybe most of progress has
made their cycles maybe a new elon musk
comes
along all those kinds of things but
it does seem that the american system of
government
has has built into it
the cycling yes that makes it effective
and it makes it last very long it lasts
a very long time
right it continues to excel and lead the
world
sure sure and let's hope it continues to
no it's
i mean we we're into you know a third
century
and democracies on this scale rarely
last that long
so that that's that's a point of pride
but it also means we need to be
attentive to keep our house in order
because
it's not inevitable that this experiment
continues
now it's important to meditate on that
actually
you